dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir this is a
neural network based technique that can
perform audio-visual separation before
we talk about what that is I will tell
you what it is not it is not what we've
seen in the previous episode where we
could select a pixel and listen to it
have a look
[Music]
and now let's try to separate the sound
of the cello and see if it knows where
it comes from
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this one is different this new technique
can clean up an audio signal by
suppressing the noise in a busy bar even
if the source of the noise is not seen
in the video it can also enhance the
voice of the speaker at the same time
let's listen
so test is uh do any video any person
who you see talking their audio gets
cleaned up did everything else gets
suppressed or if we have a Skype meeting
with someone in a lab or a busy office
where multiple people are speaking
nearby we can also perform a similar
speed separation which would be a
godsend for future meetings so we've
been trying to train this network to
input to embeddings and output 3 yeah
this is just an extra experiment for the
paper
hi guys so we've been trying to train
this network to input to embedding is it
out the three yeah this is just an extra
experiment for the paper
and I think if you are a parent the
utility of this example needs no further
explanation
how people please navigate to work
I am not sure if I ever encountered the
term screaming children in the abstract
of an AI paper so that one was also a
first here this is a super difficult
task because the AI needs to understand
what leap motions correspond to what
kind of sounds which is different for
all kinds of languages age groups and
head positions to this end the authors
put together a stupendously large data
set with almost 300,000 videos with
clean speed signals this data set is
then run through a multi stream neural
network that detects the number of human
faces within the video generates small
thumbnails of them and observes how they
move over time it also analyzes the
audio signals separately then fuses
these elements together with a recurrent
neural network to output the separated
audio waveforms a key advantage of this
architecture and training method is that
as opposed to many previous works
this is speaker independent therefore we
don't need specific training data from
the speaker we want to use this on this
is a huge leap in terms of usability the
paper also contains an excellent
demonstration of this concept by taking
a piece of footage from Conan O'Brien's
show where two comedians were booked for
the same timeslot and talk over each
other the result is a performance where
it is near impossible to understand what
they are saying but with this technique
we can hear both of them one by one
crystal-clear you see some results over
here but make sure to click the paper
link in the description to hear the
sound samples as well thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time